[Music]  the world is a mysterious place  [Music]  there are marvels of nature just waiting  to be discovered by those who are daring  enough to look Laura was like the  creature I had only heard existed in  legend a mythical monster straight out  of your worst nightmares with Wild Eyes  in a hideous face and feet that were  amazingly freakishly with perfect white  teeth and breath that just smells all  minty fresh and only hair if it has on  its entire body is on the top oh you're  scaring up hey don't be scared it's just  a story everyone knows that the small  foot isn't real  or a thief  oh that's nice real nice waitis Carm for  life  [Music]  you  you